Okay Michael so here's the little trick. So all I've done is I
have replaces the equation at the top with an alternate version of the equation.
>> 'Kay. So it looks there's, you're now exponentially blowing up the reward.
>> I am not exponentially blowing up the reward.
Instead of what I've done. Is I've added of
the see, the rewards that I'm going to see. For
the states that I'm going to see. And I multiplied
by gamma to the T. The gamma is between 0 and 1.
>> I see. So...
>> Do you?
>> Well, kind of. So, so it
doesn't exponentially blow up. It exponencially implodes.
>> Right.
>> So, so things that are like a thousand steps in
the future If we multiply, if we take something that's less
than 1 and we raise it to that power, it goes
essentially to 0. So it's like it starts off the rewards
are kind of substantial and then they get, they trail off quickly.
>> Right. And in fact we can write down mathmatically what this is If
you actually, if you stare at it
long enough and you remembered your intermediate algebra
or your calculus or wherever it is
you learned this stuff. You would probably recognize
this as a special kind of sequence or series. Do you remember what it is?
>> Television series?
>> [LAUGH].
>> No, but that's
remarkably close. So let's see if we can
bound this particular equation. So we know that
this version of the equation eventually ends up
being infinity if all the rewards are positive. Right?
>> Mm, hm-mm.
>> So what does this end up being even in the case where all
the rewards are positive? Well, we can bound this from above by the largest
reward that we will ever see, in the following way. So all I've then
is said well I don't know what the rewards are but there is some
maximum reward I'm going to call it Rmax. And if I pretended that I always
got the Rmax reward. So long as that, as long as that's an actual number.
A finite number. I know that this is bounded from above by this expression.
Well what does this look like. Maybe this does look like a series you remember.
>> Geometric series?
>> Yes. This is the geometric series. And this is exactly equal to this. .
>> And I assume that the summation
causes the max to become lower case.
>> Yes, yes it does. That's a, that's a trick that
they don't really go over deeply in calculus, but it's true.
>> Oh, that's cool. Alright so, the reward, the maximum reward
divided by 1 minus gamma. So when gamma is really close to
0, you're just getting, oh you're getting just that one reward
in the beginning and then everything falls off to nothing after that.
>> Yep.
>> And if gamma is really close to 1. You're
dividing by something that's teeny tiny, which actually is like multiplying
it by something that's really big. So it kind
of magnifies the reward out, but it's not infinity
until gamma get's all the way up to 1
and that's the same case we were in before.
>> Right, so in fact you'll notice the way I
wrote this, gamma has to be between 0 and 1, 0
inclusive but strictly less than 1. If I made it so
that it could include 1, well that's actually the first case.
>> Got it.
>> Because 1 to a power is always 1, and so,
this is actually a generalization of the sort of, infinite
sum of rewards. This is called discounted rewards, or discounted
series, or discounted sums, and it allows us, it turns
out, to go an infinite distance in finite time. Wait.
>> That makes sense.
>> No. No. [LAUGH] An infinite distance?
>> Yeah. That's at least the way I like
to think about it. So, if we're discounted in
this particular way, then that gives us a
geometric series. And what it does is it allows
us to add an infinite number of numbers,
but it actually gives us a finite number. Cool.
>> So this means we can still have our, and it
turns out, by the way, just to be clear, that this
world that we're in. Where we are in between 0 and
1, 0 inclusive is still consistent with our infinite horizons and
our stationarity over preferences. So we can add things together
and be consistent with those assumptions we were making before Or
we can do discounted rewards and we're still going to be consistent
with what we're doing before. But the difference between this case
and this case is that by doing the discount, we
get to add infinite sequences and still get something finite. The
intuition here is that Since, if gamma's less than 1, then
eventually as you raise it to a power, it will basically
become 0. I mean, that's why it's a
geometric series. Which is like having a finite horizon.
But that horizon is always the same finite distance
away, no matter what, where you are in time.
>> Which means it's effectively infinite.
>> Or unbounded, or however you want to think about it. So it's
like you take a step, but you're no closer than where, when you started.
>> Right, so, what does that mean in, a world
where you meant to say you're no closer than where
you were trying to end up? So that means that
even though, you've taken a step forward, the horizon sort
of remains a fixed distance away from where you are.
>> Mmm, mmhmm.
>> That's what it means to To, to have this kind of this
gamma value here and so you can still treat it as if it's always
going to be infinite, even though it gives you a finite value, and that
gives you your stationary. So does that make sense? I mean that's sort of
the intuition.
>> Yeah.
>> You really are have an in, you're
always in infinite, It's always in, infinity. But the
gamma value means that at any given point in
time, you only really have to think about what
amounts to a finite distance. You never get closer
to the horizon, even though you're always taking steps
towards it. But there still is a horizon that
you can see, and I can kill that analogy.
>> [LAUGH] So can we, can you explain to me why
it has this form, this R max over 1 minus gamma?
>> I could. There's a You can kind of prove that, in a little
cute math way, and I'm happy to take that diversion if you want.
>> Yeah, I think so. I mean, unless,
unless you were going to tell me something else.
>> Well how about I tell you something else and then I take that diversion?
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so here's the something else. In
the beginning I said, well, this is like going
in infinite amount of distance in finite time, which
you rebelled against. And my explanation is more about.
How infinity looks finite which is not
the same thing as going an infinite amount
of distance in finite time. The reason
I said that is beacuse of the sningularity.
>> What?
>> The singularity so, some of our listeners no doubt
have heard of the singularity. You never heard of the singularity?
>> The singularity is like when computers
get so fast that you do infinite computation
and, oh. Right. So the singularity, for those of you who don't know is is
this sort of observation that has been made by
many folks. That the sort of limit to computer
power growing faster is the fact that it takes us amount, some amount of time to
design the next generation of computers. Right, So
Moore's law says everything doubles you know, everything
6, 18 months or whatever. But if we
could design things faster, then we could actually make
it double more quickly. So, one day we'll get
to the point where the computer, which I will
draw here, like that. The computer can actually design
the next generation of computer. Well, when it designs the
next generation of computer, that computer will also have
the ability to design the next generation of computer.
But it will be able to design it twice
as fast. And then the next one will be able
to design its next successor twice as fast, and so on and so forth. So
this little time between generations, will keep Having
every single time, which looks remarkably like a
geometric sequence. And so once we reach this
point, where the computer can actually design its
successor, we will then be able to do
an infinite number of successors. In finite time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And that's when the world comes to and end.
And that's what's called the singularity. Because we can't understand
what happens after that point. So that's what I mean
by going an infinite amount of distance in finite time.
>> It just doesn't seem like distance.
But, yeah, that's a weird example, for sure.
>> I think it makes sense.
>> [INAUDIBLE] infinite number of doublings in it. Yeah, [INAUDIBLE],
no. [LAUGH] Well, we'll, we'll, we'll do we'll do some assignment
where we allow people to decide whether this
makes sense or one of your analogies make
sense. And I'll just remind the listener that
I'm the one who'll be assigning final grades.
>> Okay.
>> So with that let's go and do your little diversion.
And and then we'll come back to. Doing a whole lot
of math. So I actually think this little nice diversion will
be warmup to all the math we're going to be doing. Okay?
>> Oooh. Hm. More math.
>> Hm.